Caption: all right can we hear me
Caption: cool okay yep that's right i'm i'm cat
Caption: i'm going to be talking about what
Caption: indigenous knowledge systems or
Caption: indigenous thinking or indigenous
Caption: epistemologies can teach us about
Caption: building sophisticated ethical tech um
Caption: it's so nice to see so many familiar
Caption: faces in the crowd it's a nice cozy
Caption: audience so thank you very much for
Caption: coming along this morning there are so
Caption: many wonderful tracks and wonderful
Caption: speakers so i'm very privileged that you
Caption: chose to come here and listen to me
Caption: firstly thank you to all the amazing
Caption: sponsors who made this
Caption: this conference possible today without
Caption: their dedication and support we all
Caption: wouldn't be able to be here and do this
Caption: so
Caption: thank you sponsors
Caption: and i want to
Caption: acknowledge the traditional custodians
Caption: of the land that we're meeting on today
Caption: the wajok people of the nation
Caption: acknowledge and respect their continuing
Caption: culture and contribution to the way
Caption: the life of this city and this region
Caption: first nations peoples were the first
Caption: scientists technologists engineers and
Caption: mathematicians and i extend my respect
Caption: to our elders past and present and i
Caption: extend that respect to any of my first
Caption: nations brothers and sisters aunties or
Caption: uncles who might be listening today
Caption: so i'm kat
Caption: this is the kind of simplified version
Caption: of me
Caption: i say technologist because it's become a
Caption: nice catch-all to describe the various
Caption: hats that i've worn in the industry i
Caption: used to work in analytics and then i
Caption: moved to product management or product
Caption: development and
Caption: now i'm a consultant again
Caption: over at thoughtworks
Caption: i've worked in the tech industry for
Caption: about seven or eight years
Caption: and i used to build things but now i
Caption: simply know enough javascript to be
Caption: dangerous
Caption: i'm also a nung woman i grew up in
Caption: esperance and that continues to be the
Caption: place that i feel the closest connection
Caption: to country
Caption: and i'm an activist which sounds edgy
Caption: but mostly i just read a lot of
Caption: legislation and do a lot of panels i
Caption: serve on the board of electronic
Caption: frontiers australia fighting for digital
Caption: rights
Caption: wandering through the conference this
Caption: morning i feel like i should make a
Caption: small apology just in case you google my
Caption: name and find the panel that i did on
Caption: wednesday for abc radio perth a caller
Caption: phoned in and said that whenever they're
Caption: on the phone to their bank they unplug
Caption: their google home
Caption: and i suggested they throw it into the
Caption: ocean
Caption: so
Caption: i'm sorry to anyone who works for a
Caption: company who might smell sell smart homes
Caption: um but that's that's the lens that i'm
Caption: bringing today uh so as i'm talking
Caption: about ethical or responsible technology
Caption: i'm approaching this topic from these
Caption: specific lenses
Caption: and i found that working in technology
Caption: and engaging with activism are quite
Caption: similar they're both about oh my god
Caption: okay working in tech and engaging in
Caption: activism they're both very similar
Caption: they're about imagining different
Caption: versions of the world and trying to
Caption: usher them into existence
Caption: so at the center of this venn diagram is
Caption: where my career has led me now i'm a
Caption: lead consultant at thoughtworks and i
Caption: recently started managing their first
Caption: nations delivery center which is an
Caption: initiative to create remote first
Caption: careers in technology for aboriginal and
Caption: torres strait islander peoples in
Caption: australia
Caption: my obligatory plug page
Caption: building indigenous tech careers working
Caption: alongside communities and institutions
Caption: developing strengthening and supporting
Caption: education and employment pathways
Caption: and growing my fully remote delivery
Caption: center
Caption: so you may have seen this map before
Caption: it's a representation of the different
Caption: language groups in this country i come
Caption: from marjorie and merning people on the
Caption: south coast of western australia and
Caption: while i honor my connection to those
Caption: communities i cannot speak for them nor
Caption: can any individual and one thing i want
Caption: to highlight which i think this map
Caption: makes really clear is that indigenous
Caption: cultures are not monolithic
Caption: each area on this map represents a
Caption: country over 300 distinct groups of
Caption: people with their own culture language
Caption: customs knowledge systems and law
Caption: but there are commonalities even with
Caption: other indigenous cultures in other parts
Caption: of the world and when i say indigenous
Caption: epistemologies or knowledge systems this
Caption: includes how to navigate complex kin
Caption: systems
Caption: collective well-being
Caption: knowledge of flora and fauna and
Caption: astronomy so this bug is just really
Caption: it's really distracting me it's moving
Caption: closer and closer hang on
Caption: it's a
Caption: is it a bug or is it a feature
Caption: there you go
Caption: okay thank you
Caption: thanks cara you're a woman of many
Caption: talents um so
Caption: these knowledge systems reflect over 60
Caption: 000 years of refined knowledge and
Caption: understanding of how to live with
Caption: complex adaptive systems
Caption: so when i hear that i can only sit in
Caption: awe and reverence of the cultures that
Caption: we get to live with today
Caption: in order to sustain continuous cultures
Caption: for so many thousands of generations
Caption: aboriginal and torres strait islander
Caption: peoples have used sophisticated
Caption: knowledge systems to live in balance
Caption: with this country's ecology
Caption: these are the wear arena fish traps
Caption: they're a complex arrangement of stone
Caption: walls situated in the bowen river which
Caption: feeds into the darling river
Caption: the oldest and largest structure of
Caption: human origin
Caption: we suspect these are thousands of years
Caption: old and they represent sophisticated
Caption: technology design across different
Caption: fields of environmental sciences
Caption: including water ecology animal migration
Caption: and geography engineering hydrology and
Caption: physiology
Caption: knowledge that has been refined and
Caption: adapted over time solidified in physical
Caption: space and built to endure the
Caption: engineering of this stone fishnets
Caption: allowed the member people to trap fish
Caption: sustainably at different heights of the
Caption: river
Caption: and the fascinating thing to me is not
Caption: just the products of technology that
Caption: emerge from indigenous knowledge systems
Caption: like these fixed traps but the
Caption: information architecture that
Caption: processes that enable them
Caption: i think angie abdullah articulates this
Caption: pretty perfectly
Caption: she says indigenous knowledge is
Caption: transmitted through strict compressed
Caption: oral law to ensure its veracity
Caption: reverence relevance and ability to
Caption: sustain and nurture all life
Caption: this could be conceived as akin to code
Caption: or coding
Caption: one of my favorite examples of
Caption: indigenous knowledge literally embedded
Caption: into the technology that we use comes
Caption: from the americas
Caption: this is a woven navajo rug that featured
Caption: in a pamphlet celebrating the opening of
Caption: a new fairchild semiconductor facility
Caption: in the 60s
Caption: these rugs while beautiful also
Caption: represent generations of knowledge and
Caption: craftsmanship
Caption: the production work in that facility
Caption: relied on fairly cheap labor of
Caption: indigenous peoples
Caption: and designing circuit boards it turns
Caption: out also requires the same kind of
Caption: dedication to craft and imagination when
Caption: it comes to using the limited real
Caption: estate efficiently and effectively
Caption: and when i look at these circuit boards
Caption: i can't help but imagine what other ways
Caption: of thinking or particles of culture have
Caption: been neglected by
Caption: dominant industries that could teach us
Caption: about building the future of technology
Caption: what of basket weaving or land
Caption: management or navigating complex kinship
Caption: systems
Caption: indigenous knowledge systems is an
Caption: enormous topic
Caption: and translating between cultures
Caption: inevitably compresses complexity
Caption: particularly when we're condensing this
Caption: knowledge into a 45 minute time slot but
Caption: there are some themes that i want to
Caption: specifically talk about
Caption: so learning about indigenous knowledge
Caption: systems and their relationship to modern
Caption: technology i've noticed these themes of
Caption: sovereignty custodianship and really
Caption: relationality
Caption: they regularly appear in cultures both
Caption: here in australia and abroad
Caption: bunjalong dungani and wagoman leighton
Caption: lee describes indigenous knowledge
Caption: systems like this
Caption: when we consider knowledge systems from
Caption: a first nations perspective we're
Caption: looking at the many interconnected
Caption: relationships or pieces of knowledge
Caption: that overlap and interact with each
Caption: other without conflict this is often
Caption: referred to as kinship or balance
Caption: when first nations communities think in
Caption: systems we're seeing how the
Caption: interrelated parts of an ecosystem or
Caption: set of knowledges relate to one another
Caption: and are continuously shaped by these
Caption: interrelationships
Caption: indigenous knowledge systems are not
Caption: necessarily items or pieces of
Caption: information in discrete units or
Caption: artifacts but methods of understanding
Caption: the world
Caption: which leads us to systems theory
Caption: i'll give a quick primer in systems
Caption: theory and i won't go into too much
Caption: detail because that is a whole other
Caption: talk
Caption: but a system is essentially a set of
Caption: things interconnected in such a way that
Caption: they produce their own pattern of
Caption: behavior over time
Caption: as technology becomes more complicated
Caption: and abstracted being familiar with
Caption: systems theory as a way of thinking can
Caption: help us make sense of the world that
Caption: we're creating
Caption: a classic feature of a system is this
Caption: feedback loop with
Caption: elements or nodes or actors in a system
Caption: some kind of interconnectedness or
Caption: relationships between those elements
Caption: protocols or rules that govern how the
Caption: elements behave in a relationship to one
Caption: another
Caption: and a goal or function of the system
Caption: what is it doing what is its purpose
Caption: the one thing i want to remember is that
Caption: technology isn't neutral we like to
Caption: think that technologies like machine
Caption: learning or other types of algorithmic
Caption: decision making as purely rational and
Caption: scientific because we've somehow
Caption: abstracted ourselves away from their
Caption: output
Caption: but anything built by humans or any
Caption: human design system will exhibit bias
Caption: the risk is as more people rely on
Caption: technology for daily activities they're
Caption: also more subject to unintended and
Caption: downright hostile consequences
Caption: so what kind of protocols or rules
Caption: currently govern the technology that
Caption: we're building today
Caption: for any profit driven initiative it
Caption: might look like
Caption: collect mine extract
Caption: gather as much information and data from
Caption: as many different sources as possible
Caption: without any plan of what to do with them
Caption: or why you're collecting it
Caption: automate everything
Caption: break any task into smaller tasks to
Caption: achieve endlessly increasing
Caption: productivity
Caption: and limitless growth the perverse
Caption: incentive of limitless growth is often
Caption: unfathomable to cultures who have
Caption: maintained balance with country and
Caption: refined knowledge to persist for
Caption: millennia
Caption: and i want to reiterate that there's
Caption: nothing inevitable about these
Caption: parameters or rules that we apply to
Caption: thick technology that we can build we
Caption: can choose new ones
Caption: and the thing about a system is they
Caption: they have a terrible tendency to produce
Caption: exactly and only or you ask them to
Caption: in other words
Caption: the purpose of a system is what it does
Caption: when we see unintended consequences of
Caption: the tools that we build rather than
Caption: write those consequences off as
Caption: aberrations or outliers we must
Caption: recognize the system is doing exactly
Caption: what it was told to do and take some
Caption: responsibility
Caption: we need to build for misuse and abuse
Caption: cases not just use cases and good
Caption: intentions while necessary are not
Caption: sufficient
Caption: if the purpose of a system is what it
Caption: does
Caption: at the moment the system is setting the
Caption: ocean on fire and over policing people
Caption: of color
Caption: so what is ethical or responsible
Caption: technology
Caption: essentially it's technology that seeks
Caption: to support us and not exploit us if we
Caption: seek to address fractured political
Caption: economic and social systems i suspect
Caption: indigenous knowledge systems could be
Caption: critical to this new way of building
Caption: and we can break down this process of
Caption: building ethical technology through
Caption: these multiple lenses which i've
Caption: borrowed from a very thorough
Caption: thoughtworks guide
Caption: it isn't simply about having one person
Caption: in the room taking your product and
Caption: waving an ethics wand over it before you
Caption: go to market
Caption: but it's about interrogating
Caption: systematically the inputs outputs and
Caption: ways of working at every step of
Caption: production
Caption: about capability
Caption: constantly improving the organization
Caption: and its products it's about diversity
Caption: making sure that there is a range of
Caption: viewpoints in the room from the very
Caption: start of a project
Caption: and making sure multiple stakeholders
Caption: are considered
Caption: it's a remarkably difficult
Caption: act to imagine the viewpoint of someone
Caption: else more difficult than we expect it's
Caption: why building diverse teams is so
Caption: important it isn't just to tick a box
Caption: exercise on your rap but critical to
Caption: building technology whose purpose is to
Caption: enhance collective well-being
Caption: also about methodology
Caption: and formalizing ethical processes where
Caption: feasible
Caption: and inquiry systematically asking those
Caption: tough questions
Caption: at the beginning of this year i was
Caption: fortunate to participate in an
Caption: indigenous protocols in artificial
Caption: intelligence incubator
Caption: it was
Caption: coordinated by angie abdullah and tyson
Caption: juncker porter who hannah mentioned in
Caption: the keynote this morning
Caption: the intention of building these
Caption: protocols is to
Caption: protect indigenous communities and
Caption: natural resources
Caption: help prove improve ailing ai
Caption: reduce the harms of ai position
Caption: indigenous peoples as leading developers
Caption: to create respectful and nourishing
Caption: relationships with artificial
Caption: intelligence
Caption: and to project thanks towards
Caption: technologies so many of these protocols
Caption: i talk about today emerge from this
Caption: working group which i share with
Caption: permission
Caption: i want to take a step back
Caption: and elaborate on what an acknowledgement
Caption: means
Caption: at the beginning of my talk and at the
Caption: beginning of the conference today we
Caption: go through this
Caption: acknowledgement they've become a
Caption: commonplace ritual for a lot of events
Caption: over the past few years so it would be
Caption: very easy to become fatigued like saying
Caption: a word over and over until it loses its
Caption: meaning
Caption: but the land we're on today is unseated
Caption: which means it was stolen forcefully and
Caption: often violently
Caption: acknowledging that uninterrupted
Caption: connection to country in spite of
Caption: displacement disenfranchisement is one
Caption: step towards addressing the injustices
Caption: that indigenous people have endured and
Caption: continue to endure
Caption: australia is also the only commonwealth
Caption: country to not have a treaty with its
Caption: indigenous peoples who live across this
Caption: country
Caption: a treaty amongst other things would
Caption: recognize
Caption: this thing called indigenous sovereignty
Caption: so the concept of sovereignty is often
Caption: used to describe the independence of
Caption: nation-states
Caption: it's an entity's right to exercise
Caption: authority and govern its own affairs
Caption: without interference
Caption: and a means for indigenous peoples to
Caption: seek greater control of their lives with
Caption: limited government government
Caption: interference in indigenous affairs
Caption: and it might manifest as
Caption: self-determination or autonomy or agency
Caption: and when thinking about sovereignty in
Caption: the context of technology one way this
Caption: emerges is through indigenous data
Caption: sovereignty which allows indigenous
Caption: peoples to have control over how data is
Caption: solicited collected analyzed and
Caption: operationalized
Caption: and here data may include the digitized
Caption: collection and storage of traditional
Caption: knowledge culture
Caption: and languages
Caption: one way that we ensure sovereignty in
Caption: our own work at thoughtworks can be seen
Caption: in our approach to gila an open source
Caption: framework built by thought workers to
Caption: allow communities with endangered
Caption: languages to build
Caption: apps that help preserve their culture
Caption: this project predates me by a few years
Caption: but it was one of those projects that
Caption: instantly made me feel proud to work
Caption: where i do
Caption: the framework itself is free to use so
Caption: any language group can use these tools
Caption: in their own language for revitalization
Caption: efforts and apps are developed in close
Caption: consultation and collaboration with
Caption: those language groups and any output or
Caption: app is owned by the traditional
Caption: custodians
Caption: so i'd like to set a new standard for
Caption: the way that we approach building tech
Caption: i argue that the protocols that we
Caption: extend to indigenous or other vulnerable
Caption: groups should form the new standard of
Caption: care taking when building technology or
Caption: handling data
Caption: in its current state digital platforms
Caption: like facebook or twitter or tick doc or
Caption: really any website across the internet
Caption: collect data from its users with
Caption: insatiability
Caption: shana zubov uses the term surveillance
Caption: capitalism to describe the operating
Caption: model of surveilling customers to
Caption: collect data create audiences of
Caption: like-minded people and incrementally
Caption: influence human behavior
Caption: it's a system that sees data as the new
Caption: oil and people as fracking opportunities
Caption: in a wildly imbalanced brokerage
Caption: relationship between platform platforms
Caption: and companies with an abundance of
Caption: information and power and users who see
Caption: very little about how their behavior is
Caption: mined for profit
Caption: it's a system devoid of respect for
Caption: human agency and autonomy
Caption: and i think it's on all of us to build
Caption: something a bit better
Caption: so everything exists in relation to
Caption: something and the system it lives in
Caption: relationality refers to the
Caption: relationships and responsibilities
Caption: between peoples country entities stories
Caption: both human and
Caption: non-human and it recognizes country as
Caption: an entity in itself
Caption: how can we design technology that
Caption: recognizes how humans and non-humans are
Caption: related to and
Caption: interdependent on each other
Caption: in this essay titled making kin with the
Caption: machines jason edward lewis reckons with
Caption: this idea of how to relate with
Caption: technology through an indigenous lens
Caption: they suggest indigenous epistemologies
Caption: are much better at respectfully
Caption: accommodating the non-human
Caption: it's not a new concept to assign agency
Caption: and autonomy to non-human entities
Caption: or show them the due respect or
Caption: reverence they deserve
Caption: when looking at it through an indigenous
Caption: perspective
Caption: they also go on to say we retain a sense
Caption: of community that is articulated through
Caption: complex kin networks anchored in
Caption: specific territories genealogies and
Caption: protocols and ultimately our goal is
Caption: that we as a species figure out how to
Caption: treat these new non-human kin
Caption: respectfully and reciprocally and not as
Caption: mere tools or worse slaves to their
Caption: creators
Caption: so these are the kind of protocols that
Caption: might emerge from this concept of
Caption: relationality
Caption: defined protocols in relation to
Caption: handling sacred images text audio it's a
Caption: standard practice to provide context
Caption: warnings for example before showing
Caption: depictions of deceased aboriginal
Caption: peoples
Caption: to allow for appropriate cultural
Caption: protocols to be followed
Caption: similarly anticipating these cultural
Caption: pathways and interpretations for both
Caption: indigenous and non-indigenous groups of
Caption: people may assist with content
Caption: moderation
Caption: in its present form content moderation
Caption: is typically a platform-wide exercise
Caption: leading to content that is frequently
Caption: banned to appease the lowest common
Caption: denominator or highest bid
Caption: this doesn't necessarily reflect the
Caption: nature of our society if we could allow
Caption: groups of people to define their own
Caption: protocols or content warnings we can
Caption: shift responsibility away from platforms
Caption: and closer to the traditional custodians
Caption: of that information
Caption: rather than the impossible task of
Caption: delivering material appropriate to every
Caption: person on the planet
Caption: the terms of use of data sets ought to
Caption: be determined by the communities related
Caption: to them in close consultation with those
Caption: communities and data should not leave
Caption: country without the permission of
Caption: custodian
Caption: there is also this concept of
Caption: multi-generational custodianship of data
Caption: in the same way that we might create
Caption: handover documentation as we're leaving
Caption: a position or a job and onto something
Caption: else
Caption: we might
Caption: develop protocols or define ways of
Caption: working with data as well and how it can
Caption: be treated respectfully
Caption: i want to draw attention to some
Caption: emerging examples of digitization of
Caption: cultural knowledge that hasn't followed
Caption: protocols of custodianship
Caption: these are assets
Caption: available to download from sketchfab
Caption: and many of these artifacts are subject
Caption: to cultural protocol in their use and
Caption: sharing
Caption: they might be involved in ceremonies or
Caption: very sacred to particular peoples
Caption: these images were brought to my
Caption: attention by gabriel woman michaela jade
Caption: who runs an indigenous digital skills
Caption: training program called in digital
Caption: and she argues that these artifacts are
Caption: sacred hold cultural knowledge and are
Caption: subject to careful custodianship
Caption: so why are 3d scans of places and
Caption: objects not subject to the same respect
Caption: and responsibility
Caption: there is this risk as technology grows
Caption: and proliferates of sharing information
Caption: beyond its intended audience or
Caption: contributing further to the colonization
Caption: and violence towards indigenous
Caption: communities
Caption: so if you're working with any kind of
Caption: indigenous knowledge cultural practices
Caption: references artifacts stories
Caption: consultation with relevant custodians is
Caption: essential
Caption: in the book braiding sweet grass by
Caption: robin wall kimura
Caption: they say each person human or no is
Caption: bound to every other in a reciprocal
Caption: relationship
Caption: they go on to say just as all beings
Caption: have duty to me i have a duty to them
Caption: if an animal gives its life to feed me i
Caption: am in turn bound to support its life
Caption: if i receive a stream's gift of pure
Caption: water then i am responsible for
Caption: returning a gift in kind
Caption: an integral part of a human's education
Caption: is to know those duties and how to
Caption: perform them
Caption: this is how we arrive at that kinship
Caption: and balance of an ecosystem
Caption: so custodianship emerges from this idea
Caption: of relationality as responsibility
Caption: when talking about land management
Caption: custodianship may mean responsibility
Caption: and deep connection to lands waters
Caption: animals plants and ecosystems
Caption: and i want to make the distinction
Caption: between custodianship and ownership
Caption: modern technology built from western
Caption: epistemologies prioritizes this
Caption: custodianship of
Caption: this concept of ownership
Caption: this is mine whatever i've collected
Caption: belongs to me and i can make a profit
Caption: off it someday probably
Caption: custodians have a responsibility on the
Caption: other hand to care for country
Caption: and recognize that country health and
Caption: culture are all connected
Caption: so particularly when thinking about data
Caption: governance and data protection we can
Caption: apply this concept of custodianship and
Caption: taking only what you need and extend it
Caption: to data minimization practices
Caption: so
Caption: who are the custodians of digital
Caption: landscapes
Caption: if they don't exist in a physical space
Caption: it's hard to tell who owns it or who is
Caption: the custodian of it
Caption: but arguably we are all custodians
Caption: every person who has a hand in building
Caption: technology has some responsibility to
Caption: the outcomes of those digital systems
Caption: the internet is a shared resource like
Caption: an environmental one
Caption: like food or
Caption: water
Caption: and perverse incentives like limitless
Caption: growth and mining human behavior for
Caption: profit can be antithetical to a world
Caption: that wants to enhance collective
Caption: well-being
Caption: in the book future histories lizzie
Caption: oshie talks a little about drawing on
Caption: the works of indigenous activists to
Caption: create better digital futures she says
Caption: we need to create a digital environment
Caption: that is not owned by anyone or any
Caption: entity but is preserved and protected
Caption: for a shared future based on a culture
Caption: of mutual respect
Caption: this is a sentiment that i carry into my
Caption: own work
Caption: but i think it has the chance to
Caption: proliferate through the networks and
Caption: shared infrastructures of our industry
Caption: so these are some of the viewpoints and
Caption: protocols that i'm beginning to embed
Caption: into my own practices of building
Caption: technology
Caption: and as i'm learning how to build more
Caption: diverse teams as well
Caption: and i want to leave you with some notes
Caption: about creating space for indigenous
Caption: technologists on your teams if you
Caption: manage to find any
Caption: and good luck so aboriginal and torres
Caption: strait islander peoples make up roughly
Caption: three percent of the general population
Caption: and closer to zero percent of the tech
Caption: industry
Caption: we
Caption: think the number is sitting around 100
Caption: software developers in australia
Caption: and i think i probably know all of them
Caption: by name
Caption: so
Caption: good luck um
Caption: building a diverse team by throwing a
Caption: bunch of differently experienced people
Caption: into a room isn't
Caption: necessarily sufficient to building
Caption: ethical technology but also it's
Caption: important to create safe space
Caption: and not all spaces are made equal
Caption: we may leverage tools and platforms like
Caption: twitter and facebook and instagram to
Caption: find our mates but that isn't their
Caption: business model
Caption: these platforms are more like data farms
Caption: that also happen to be good at
Caption: connecting people so when we're
Caption: navigating our teams in this industry
Caption: using digital tools designed to extract
Caption: and conquer sovereignty is already
Caption: something to be reclaimed rather than
Caption: baked into its scaffolding
Caption: we need spaces that not only serve us
Caption: but protect us too
Caption: and the culturally safe space is one
Caption: where we can find appropriate support
Caption: a space where people can ask for help
Caption: from members of their own community and
Caption: know the support we receive will be
Caption: culturally relevant
Caption: the cultural shock waves of the black
Caption: lives matter movements across the us
Caption: which have reverberated into our own
Caption: reflection of australia's treatment of
Caption: first nations people have carried with a
Caption: swarm of well-meaning allies who want to
Caption: do more to support us but please don't
Caption: expect indigenous peoples to be your
Caption: personal educators when reckoning with
Caption: your own journey
Caption: and this particularly includes expecting
Caption: aboriginal and torres strait islander
Caption: peoples on your teams to do cultural
Caption: work outside of their job description
Caption: such as advising or consulting on
Caption: matters of cultural protocols
Caption: and people sometimes have a sense of
Caption: entitlement when it comes to culture
Caption: there's this western view that stories
Caption: are meant to be told
Caption: and culture is meant to be shared but we
Caption: have our own very sacred protocols to
Caption: navigate when engaging with culture
Caption: who to ask permission from
Caption: which stories are allowed to be told
Caption: with which kind of people and
Caption: negotiating who has access to the
Caption: stories of our old people is fundamental
Caption: to preserving their integrity
Caption: as i said
Caption: aboriginal and torres strait islander
Caption: people make up three percent of the
Caption: population but closer to zero percent of
Caption: the tech industry it's more of a
Caption: rounding error really
Caption: and there's something about knowledge
Caption: systems that have successfully
Caption: transferred information from one tech
Caption: from one generation to the next for tens
Caption: of thousands of years that floors me and
Caption: bringing a multitude of experiences and
Caption: ways of thinking to a team means we're
Caption: better placed to avoid building hostile
Caption: technology
Caption: and a future of ethical technology
Caption: designed to maximize all of our
Caption: well-beings
Caption: all right okay i have a further reading
Caption: list on my website but otherwise thank
Caption: you very much everyone for coming today
Caption: thanks so much kat really great to get
Caption: that insight i'm sure cat will be around
Caption: for the rest of the day if anyone wants
Caption: to ask